[Musique]
à l'arrivée en touraine à l'âge de c'est
un passionné de photo à 12 il devient
professionnel à 18 olivier aime pas là
dedans dehors d'avoir été un grand
photographe de presse chez gamma formés
aux bons soins du studio harcourt se
singularise par sa marotte de toujours
photographier des personnalités oui mais
dans le même fauteuil
[Musique]
la star en fin de compte c'est le
fauteuil et ce qui est assez intéressant
parce que des personnages comme
même belmondo ou aux scènes et des gens
c'est important qu'ils sont quand même
très reconnue en france quand ils me
posent la question qui a été
photographiée sur le fauteuil que je
parle de danza washington et le strip ou
allen ils sont impressionnés d'un seul
coup ça les rames amène comme des petits
enfants il se livre totalement ils sont
impressionnés par par le fauteuil donc
c'est vraiment je pense à cluny la star
c'est le fauteuil tour événement rend
hommage à ces portrait réalisé en france
mais ce boulimique de photographies a
longtemps travaillé à genève washington
et new york
il rentrera en france après les
événements du 11 septembre
depuis 25 ans il promène son fauteuil
dans le monde et ce n'est pas toujours
de tout repos mais arrivé de porter sur
ma tête pour hanter des étages à pied
pas d'ascenseur bon c'est quand même
gros fauteuils moi j'ai une toute petite
voiture donc c'était toujours très
compliqué pour le transporter le
fauteuil là-bas 25 ans maintenant et il
ya des gens qui s'asseyait sur
l'accoudoir qui est en bois donc
maintenant le vernis est parti parce
qu'à force de des pantalons qui frotte
dessus le siège s'est affaissé mais d'un
autre côté je trouve ça sympathique
parce que il ya une histoire lui aussi
et beaucoup d'artistes ont signé en
dessous sous la toile du fauteuil toile
blanche j'ai beaucoup d'artistes
paiement de parapher le fauteuil donc
c'est une pièce de musée le fauteuil de
ce faux calme rassurant a fait de lui la
nuit voire le confident de ceux qui le
temps d'un moment se pose en toute
liberté lui sans boîtier son fauteuil
reviendront en fin janvier pour
immortaliser des personnalités toro gel
et ses secrets
[Musique]